estamos en un barrio popular al norte de
nápoles en donde se encuentra uno de los
tesoros más grandes que pueda tener esta
ciudad pero para llegar aquí hay que
hablar con los locales porque no está en
ningún mapa aquí dentro de este sótano
se encuentra un verdadero santuario
hecho para diego armando maradona hay
cientos miles de objetos que
pertenecieron a la 10 cuando jugaba con
él a nápoles aquí en esta ciudad
italiana es de verdad un lugar perfecto
un paraíso para los amantes del fútbol y
sobre todo de maradona pues son muy se
dedica también este es un museo dedicado
a mi padre y a diego porque tuve la
suerte de que mi padre fuera durante 35
años el encargado del estadio de san
paolo y sobre todo de los vestuarios mi
madre era la cocinera y ama de llaves de
la casa maradona y mi hermana la niñera
de dalma y de giannina son todos los
recuerdos que le regaló a toda mi
familia para mí maradona yo perdí un
hermano mi mamá un hijo que sufrió
de los miles de objetos que hay aquí
quizás este es uno de los más
representativos de esta chaqueta que
seguramente ustedes reconocen que
utilizó el astro argentino cuando
calentaba para la final de la copa de la
uefa en 1989 copa que ganó con el napoli
pero además de esto hay recortes de
periódicos raquetas que le pertenecieron
al 10 e incluso el contrato que firmó
cuando llegó de barcelona hacia aquí
hacia nápoles en 1984 todo el paso de
diego armando maradona durante los siete
años que estuvo aquí en nápoles todo eso
se puede prácticamente vivir aquí
digo era diego era un campeón aún más
grande fuera de la cancha que dentro de
ella una persona generosa una persona
con un corazón grande una persona
humilde así nació porque diego no está
muerto
diego vive su cuerpo no está más pero su
espíritu permanece entero
entre los otros feos que se pueden
encontrar aquí está este balón el balón
con el que el nápoles consiguió su
primer scudetto en 1987 y otro de los
objetos increíbles tengo aquí en mi mano
nada más y nada menos que el zapato de
dios es aquel que el barrilete cósmico
la zurda del barrilete cósmico utilizó
durante la mundial de méxico en 1986
este lugar se puede visitar
gratuitamente pero se invita a dejar una
donación porque todas estas donaciones
serán dadas a los niños desfavorecidos
de nápoles por ahora máximo vignatti
pues se espera mantener este lugar
abierto pero él quisiera quizás en un
futuro que todo este museo pues se tenga
un lugar dedicado en el futuro estadio
diego armando maradona aquí en nápoles